meanwhile NASA can you believe the
honeymoon is over for Kelly
early this weekend Kevin got back to
work at a fan event in Portland and that
is where I caught up with him and he
talked for the first time about his new
life as a married man
I noticed that bling on your fingers
should bury down this chocolate is
locked up ladies
yes do you remember your wedding because
I remember the picture of you on the
ground do you remember the wedding no I
woke up in the morning with grass stains
on my shirt
until this day they say I passed out
some people said I jumped in the pool
for no reason at all it got bad
Kevin's appearance a total surprise to a
Portland audience who won tickets to see
his new stand-up film what now earlier I
learned all about that Hart honeymoon I
took my baby ooh you I did I get the
woman when I get the woman you got
nothing left will tell me one of the
whoo steps you wanted a woman moment
yeah a move moment a beachfront dinner
you know on the sand feet in the sand
water coming up while you eat I'm a
romantic guy man so it was like a
lover's holiday I mean look it was love
was holiday she's she's smitten oh right
now Kevin gets major laughs out of
personal stories they drive his stand up
in the film which you don't know is
Kevin was in a lot of pain and was
hobbling because just before coming to
the screening he ran in the Mount Hood
to Coast relay how many miles did you
run
I've ran I think 18.3 what do you think
that's basically a marathon it's
basically a marathon you know I'm
getting
to the place where I want to challenge
myself kid